[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan and
this is your update
about all the cool
developer news
from Google in the last week.
Speaking of weeks, it's
just over five weeks
until Google I/O. That's
not really an update.
I'm just excited.
OK.
Now for something really cool.
Have you wanted to implement
machine learning into your app,
but didn't want to take
the time to get the PhD?
Well, Josh Gordon has a
new video series for you.
Machine Learning Recipes
for New Developers.
Click the link for the first
episode and your introduction
to machine learning.
Cardboard is it again.
And now there is
an easy way for you
to embed immersive content
on Android iOS and the web
with a VR view from
the Cardboard SDK.
And, yes, you heard me right.
A native Cardboard SDK
is now available for iOS.
Click through to the blog
post for all the links.
Learn how to use flexibility to
your advantage with these tips
from the Director of
Business Development at MOBI
systems, the company
behind Office Suite,
a successful mobile office
solution for Android
with a user base of
over 200 million.
This is the latest post
from the inside AdMob blog
series featuring
monetization tips straight
from successful app developers.
The 2016 Android
experiments I/O challenge
is now ready for your code.
The top three winners
of this contest
will receive a trip to
this year's Google I/O
and the five runner-ups
will get the new Nexus 6p.
From now through
April 13th, you can
enter by submitting your
experiments to the gallery.
The Google Cloud data
store is simplifying
pricing which will
cut costs dramatically
for most use cases.
Cloud Datastore is a highly
scalable, no SQL database,
for Web and mobile applications.
Along with a simpler
pricing model,
it will be a more transparent
method of calculating
stored data in Cloud Datastore.
See the blog post
for all the details.
Also new from the
Google Cloud platform,
you can now resize Google
Cloud persistent disks
without downtime.
With this feature, persistent
disk capacity planning
becomes much simpler.
It's as easy as a button
click or a single API call,
doesn't cause any downtime
to Google Compute Engine
instances, doesn't
require snapshotting,
and it applies to all persistent
disks including the recently
announced 64 terabyte volumes.
One last thing.
If you missed any of the fun
Google April fools jokes,
take a look at Venture
Beats Round Up,
linked, along with everything
else, in the description below.
Remember to like this video.
And don't forget to subscribe.
I'm Timothy Jordan and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]